Narrator: Tonight on the
season finale of "Shark Tank"...
Mullin: We partner with the best
coffee farms in Vietnam.
It is out of this world.
We make the most accurate
dinosaurs, full size.
I'll buy that one right now.
Let's fill your bank
with a lot of cash.
You're a wolf
in sheep's clothing.
Make me an offer.
50%.
You came here too early,
and you asked too much.
You want to lose
$1.4 million? Give it to me.
That is so disrespectful.
This is wrong.
That's insane.
Could you shut up?
Did not see that one coming.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a giant business
based on a childhood favorite.
♪♪
Together: Yo, Sharks.
I'm "Dino" Don Lessem
from Philadelphia.
I'm Val Jones, and
I'm married to this guy.
And we're excited to
be here
to ask you
for 500,000 bucks
in exchange for 10%
of our company, Dino Don, Inc.
Wow.
When it comes to
dinosaurs,
Don is a big deal.
He's a dinosaur explorer
who's excavated and recreated
the biggest dinosaurs
that ever roamed the Earth.
He's one of a handful
of human beings alive today
who's actually had a dinosaur
named after him ‐‐
the Lessemsaurus.
He's written dozens of books
about dinosaurs,
and he was science advisor
to Steven Spielberg
on "Jurassic Park."
‐Wow.
‐Cool.
And Val, well, she just
loves spreadsheets.
She's raised
millions of dollars
for nonprofits,
zoos, and museums,
and she's
our financial mastermind.
We distinguish ourselves
by creating the most accurate
and educational dinosaurs
ever made,
and they're always
full size.
That means
up to 110 feet long.
Greiner: Wow.
You're looking at
a little Dakotaraptor.
A relative, a velociraptor,
is even smaller,
and this is just
a juvenile T. rex.
When they grow up,
they're 40 feet long.
They have a mouth big enough
to eat all of you.
Wow.
[ Dinosaur roars ]
‐Oh!
‐Wow!
[ Laughter ]
[ Roaring ]
Whoa!
That's cool.
Lessem:
Look closely.
You won't believe
how realistic they are.
‐Oh, whoa.
‐Oh, look at the eyes.
Wow. [ Laughs ]
I would think
there's somebody in that.
[ Roaring ]
Cuban: Very cool.
We just started making
these robots last year,
and we're already the leading
supplier in the United States.
So, dinosaurs are a big staple
of museums and zoos ‐‐
that's how they increase
their attendance.
But these institutions
are in trouble right now,
so we've come up with
a unique gate‐sharing plan
that will increase our revenue,
at the same time
getting them back
on their feet.
But also, we really need
your expertise to expand.
So, what do you say,
Sharks?
Do you want to make
millions of kids happy,
or do you want to
have to apologize
for the rest of your life
to your children
and grandchildren?
[ Laughter ]
That's up to you.
So, what got you into
dinosaurs, Dino Don?
Well, I wasn't
a dinosaur nerd as a kid.
I was a reporter
for The Boston Globe,
and they sent me out
on a dinosaur story,
and I just fell in love with
this wonderful treasure hunt ‐‐
that you're searching
for lost animals
and you could be the first
person who ever saw this animal.
Well, Kevin,
you were there originally.
Are these realistic?
[ Chuckles ]
They look ‐‐ You know,
they look just like I remember.
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: Is this the average
size of the robots
that you're going to make?
Lessem: No.
One of the things
that distinguishes us is
we make the most accurate
and realistic animals
full size ‐‐
up to 110 feet long.
You can't see animals
this size anywhere else.
Wow.
So it's only in the movie?
So there's nowhere
to actually go and see them?
Even in the movie, I can tell
you from "Jurassic Park,"
the animals were cut in half
so they could get a close‐up.
I would say all the time,
"This is wrong."
And they would say,
"Could you shut up?"
So what I did was
I said, "Spielberg," or "Steven,
when you're done here,
can I have all
the sets and props?
I'm going to make
an exhibit,
and we're going to
raise money for research."
We raised $3 million.
It was the most attended
exhibit
in the history
of natural science.
‐Wow.
It's what got me started
in the exhibition business.
Our business is we tour groups
of these dinosaurs
to zoos and museums,
and they increase
the attendance of the zoos ‐‐
just their presence ‐‐
15% to 50%.
I'll give you an example.
Last year,
we did a big exhibit,
45 dinosaurs.
440,000 people went
just to see the dinosaurs,
paying $6 additional a person.
They made $2.2 million.
Wow.
How much does it cost
to make an average dinosaur?
Jones: What do you think
it would cost?
$40,000?
What do you think,
Mark?
$18,000.
I think it's about
50 grand.
15.
5.
‐$5,000?
‐5 grand to make that?
I win!
John: [ Laughs ]
O'Leary: Are you kidding?
That's what it costs to make.
Greiner: Wow.
I'll buy that
one right now.
So that's why I say
the percentage is...
I'll buy that one
right now.
That's crazy.
I'll give you 10
for that one.
I'll give you 11.
[ Roaring ]
The point is not to
sell them.
The point is to make them,
rent them.
Zoos, you can attend
pretty safely outdoors,
so this is a big attraction
for them to boost attendance.
So, guys, part of your premise
here is that the zoos
are bringing in $2 million
or plus in revenue.
You feel like you should be
getting a percentage of that
rather than
just charging a flat fee?
It's not quite that.
First of all,
the zoos used to pay us.
They don't have money
anymore.
That's why we want to
do a gate share with them,
because they don't have
the money,
and we're going to help them
get back to health.
And is that because of
the pandemic?
Just this year.
Yeah.
OK. So now, you guys,
your revenue has dropped off
and fallen off a cliff,
basically.
Actually, no.
OK.
We've done
very well.
Last year, we did
$1.6 million.
This year, even with
the pandemic,
we're at $1.8 million.
Wow. How many dinosaurs
do you have ready to go on tour?
We have 150 dinosaurs
and the largest collection
of fossil skeletons.
Wow.
Greiner: 150?
We paid $1 million
for this stuff.
If we rent it
like we do the others,
it's $10 million
over five years.
OK, tell us about the economics
of the tour.
Seven months,
nine venues,
about three weeks
a venue.
12 staff to set it up.
Short run.
$40,000 a market.
We got the staff costs
of about $60,000.
We have the set up
of the technicians ‐‐
$20,000 ‐‐
and the dinosaurs are ours.
So that's it.
One full year from now,
what will you do?
$3 million
in the first‐‐
Next year.
Yeah. Yeah.
Plus whatever
gate share.
What do you think you'll make
on the $3 million?
Greiner: Yeah.
Last two years,
we made $250,000 profit.
So I actually will have to last
as long as a dinosaur
to ever get my money back.
No, that's not true,
because the profit
is going to go up hugely.
Next year,
$3 million in sales,
$2 million in profit.
No way.
That doesn't make sense.
Nah. Never.
3 staff ‐‐ We're not
paying those expenses.
O'Leary:
No business can do that.
I mean, look, you've got to
give me real numbers.
I don't believe that.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
but Kevin is skeptical
about Don and Val's projections
for their robotic dinosaur
company, Dino Don.
I mean, look. You've got to
give me real numbers.
I don't believe that.
You're all over the map
on terms of how you turn this
into a defined business.
I don't have the confidence,
Don, that you can execute.
I'm out.
I like to add value
to the companies I invest in,
and I just don't think
you need my help,
so I'm out.
I think it's
a very cool idea,
but if you had come in
with a mocked‐up board
so I can visually see,
here's the zoo,
this is how they exhibit it,
it would have been
very helpful.
All right. We'll come back
tomorrow with the board.
But you understand
what I'm saying?
Yes. Yeah.
Absolutely.
And it's really important.
I'm sorry.
I find a visual
is worth a thousand words.
But because I didn't
get all that today,
unfortunately, sadly,
I'm out.
This is sad.
Sorry, too.
Guys, look, I like the idea.
♪♪
I really do, and I think
I can help you with marketing.
Have you explored working
with any of the big
concert promotion companies
at all?
Not yet.
So, I can introduce
you there, right...
That would be big.
...because this is
their business, and guess what?
They're dying right now.
I'm going to
make you an offer.
Whoa.
Wow.
I'll offer you
the $500,000,
but I want 25%,
because it's going to be
a lot of work,
and I'm going to have
to dedicate a lot of people
and put in a lot of time.
‐Wow.
OK, I ‐‐
Super generous, so way more
than I was thinking.
O'Leary: What were you
going to offer, Robert?
So I'm out.
Well, you're going to ‐‐
you're going to generate
a lot more money for us.
Yes.
So that is great.
25% is an awfully
big chunk
for a company
that's already making...
Oh‐ho.
Hold on.
You're not making the deal.
I'm making the deal.
[ Laughter ]
It's true!
Lessem: So, 25%...
But, guys, look.
...is a big chunk.
If you didn't need help,
you wouldn't be here.
Absolutely.
What you've discussed
is, you know,
$1.8 million in sales
going to 3,
you're hoping,
but that's just based off
of what you already know.
Right.
You don't know what I know.
Yes.
So it really ‐‐ it's up to you.
We really appreciate it.
Um...
What do you say?
♪♪
We'll do it.
Jones:
Thank you so much!
Done!
I want you to know
how much we believe in you.
[ Laughter ]
No, you had that ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
John: Don. Don.
This is going to be
a total game‐changer.
Before you go, you know
any good dinosaur jokes?
What do you call somebody
who puts their right arm
in a velociraptor's mouth?
What?
[ Chuckles ]
‐A lefty?
‐Lefty?
‐A lefty.
[ Laughter ]
I knew they knew these.
[ Roaring ]
Greiner: Bye, guys.
Thanks, guys.
‐Bye.
‐Congrats.
I've been doing dinosaurs
for 30 years
because I see
what it does for children.
They love dinosaurs
and they always will,
and we're bringing them
more dinosaurs
than anybody ever has ‐‐
and bigger, too.
Narrator: This season was like
no other for "Shark Tank."
Together with the Venetian
Resort in Las Vegas,
we created a protected
bubble environment
to keep our entrepreneurs,
Sharks, and crew
as safe as possible
from COVID‐19.
Though the past year has been
one of the most challenging
for the entire world,
"Shark Tank" businesses
have persevered,
given back, and even thrived.
The future has a lot of great
potential for you guys.
Kislevitz: With people
trying to figure out
ways to work out at home,
we sold out immediately.
Now, in just 5 months,
we've done $7.5 million.
Lewis: I knew that we had to
find a way
to help our business owners
earn an income again.
We had just partnered
with 1‐800‐Flowers,
and our new virtual
experiences were born.
Evans: We supplied everyday
essential goods
out of our drive‐thru window
and donated to local
hospital workers,
police stations,
and fire departments
to thank them
for their service.
O'Leary: We've accelerated
the digitization
of the American economy.
This is a whole new America,
and it's a really good one.
Sodemann: Boho isn't just
a business anymore ‐‐
it's a way for people
to get outside,
spend time with their families,
spend time with their friends.
It feels good to be able
to provide that to people.
Kupper: There are so many people
dealing with anxiety, insomnia.
So it's been really rewarding
to help thousands of people
at least get
a better night's sleep.
Crowley: For every
Baby Toon sold,
we donate to the International
Fund of Animal Welfare.
Some of our sales
will go to protect animals
and their habitats.
Connors: The new customers
who found us after "Shark Tank"
helped create 200,000 hours
of employment
for our weavers in Thailand.
Durity:
As a Black‐owned business,
it's very important for me
to succeed,
because I represent the idea ‐‐
someone that looks like me
can succeed in America.
It gives the culture hope.
Skaya: We're doing important
work in feline cancer,
feline diabetes in the hopes of
helping create therapeutics
to make sure that our cats
are staying stay healthy.
King: One of the biggest lessons
the military teaches you
is to leave it better
than you found it.
And it's been
that guiding principle
that's helped us here
in our hometown.
Whoo!
With this partnership,
we're going to take your product
to the masses.
Altieri: In the year since
"Shark Tank,"
we have tripled sales
to over $15 million.
Martin: We've sold over
7.5 million bags of Pipcorn
and done over $18 million
in sales.
Lutz: Hungry Harvest has
delivered over 2 million boxes
to hundreds of thousands
of households
across the United States.
We've now done $50 million
in sales.
I can't wait to see you
in person
when this whole thing
is over
and be able to give you
a big ol' hug.
John: I have so much hope
for our next generation
of entrepreneurs.
They are out here
to change the planet,
reach for the stars,
and they are
inspiring me, as well.
Cuban: This pandemic, everybody
has had to change in every way.
As bad as it is,
wherever there's change,
there's opportunity.
We will come out of this,
and there will be entrepreneurs
that take this moment
and will change the world.
As painful as it may be,
there will be good
that comes out of this.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a way to have
a popular Vietnamese beverage
at home.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Debbie,
and I'm here today
seeking $600,000
in exchange for 4%
of my company.
‐Whoa!
‐Ohhhhh!
Wowza!
Mullin: [ Laughs ]
My mom immigrated here
from Vietnam,
and even though I was born
and raised in California,
make no mistake,
I was definitely raised
in a Vietnamese household.
And I loved
everything about it ‐‐
I loved the food,
I loved the culture,
and I especially loved
the sweet, creamy treat
of Vietnamese coffee.
If you're not familiar with it,
it's just a simple,
dark‐roasted coffee
that's paired with sweetened
condensed milk,
and it is out of this world.
Sharks, nowadays, people are
looking more than ever
for that coffee shop experience,
and Copper Cow Coffee
is exactly that.
Our single, individual
pour‐overs
allow for anyone
to make a gourmet coffee
without any additional
equipment.
Simply take your pour‐over,
open it up, and grab
your biodegradable filter.
Gently hang it over your cup,
and then tear off the top,
and then pour hot water
over the organic grounds
and immediately watch
as your organic coffee
drips directly into the cup.
And we partner with
the best farms in Vietnam
to bring the absolute
best Vietnamese coffee
to the U. S.
Once brewed, then you get to add
your Copper Cow Creamer,
and there is nothing else
like it on the market ‐‐
there are no preservatives
or additives.
And then stir,
and within seconds,
you will be sipping on your own
perfectly balanced
Vietnamese coffee.
So Sharks, tell me ‐‐ who's
ready to be their own barista?
O'Leary: Tell us about
what's in front of us, Debbie.
Yeah, so, what you have
in front of you
is a sampling of
our best‐selling products.
You, of course,
have the classic,
which is what I just made here,
that comes with
the milk and sugar.
But we also have it just black.
And then on your far right,
you've got our churro
and our lavender.
They're natural infusions,
and trust me,
they're all delicious.
I got to tell you, you know,
this packaging is
absolutely incredible.
Thank you.
And I just came back
from Ho Chi Minh,
and I stood on line
two hours
for one coffee shop.
Yup.
Now, I learned how to ‐‐
Herjavec: Really?
Now, are you telling me
that I didn't have to
wait out there
for two hours?
Nope. And you don't need to buy
any additional equipment.
This is great.
Why is it so sweet?
Well, we do sell it just black,
but we do find that most ‐‐
just like most Americans
drink their coffee
with milk and sugar, that's how
most people want to buy it.
Robert, that's the culture.
Philippines, Vietnam...
Yeah. Oh, yeah.
...that's the profile.
That's the
flavor profile.
It's actually normally
much sweeter in Vietnam.
Yeah.
It's like it packs
a punch, for sure.
So, what's your story?
Ohh.
How did you come up
with this?
Yes, so my background is,
is that I went to M. I. T.
and Berkeley.
I ended up working
at the World Bank
in finance supply‐chain
management,
and I wanted to do something
that really was more creative,
something where I could go
a million miles per hour.
During the last year
at the World Bank,
I did this on the side.
I was on the subway with
a duffel bag full of samples
selling door to door
to get into our first 30 stores
and, you know, was manufacturing
and living with my sister,
making it out of her garage.
When was this?
This was four years ago.
What I think is
really cool is this.
I've never seen
anything like it.
It's really clever,
this packaging.
Yes.
Did you create
this yourself?
We perfected it in terms of
exactly the brew that we want,
but it's actually a technology
that's very common in Japan...
It's fantastic.
...and so we're the first people
to be bringing it over.
And how much does this
sell for?
$15 for five servings,
and it costs us $3.10
to make it.
So it's premium coffee.
It's premium coffee.
So I took it
to the Fancy Food Show,
and I was chosen
as the Innovation of the Show,
Really?
and so we got into
a thousand stores that month.
What year was that?
2017.
So total sales to date
is $4 million.
$4 million?!
$4 million all ‐‐
People, let her
go through.
Please, go ahead.
2017, $170,000.
OK. '18?
And then in 2018,
we make $500,000.
OK, then?
Then in '19,
we make $1.6 million.
Whoa!
And year to date?
Year to date
is $2 million.
Wow.
Tell me
the margins, now.
Now we have
a 70% margin.
Greiner: Wow.
So you're doing $2 million
year to date, right?
Yes. Yes.
So what percentage of that
is online?
That's 80% online.
Wow. There you go.
OK, so that's your real
business outlet.
80%.
You've evolved
from being retail,
which is good
for you now, right?
Mullin: Right.
And retail ‐‐
we're still in retail.
That 20% is ‐‐
that's from a growing number.
Last year, when your sales
were $1.6 million,
how much money
did you lose?
We lost $1.4 million.
‐What!
‐Whoa!
‐$1.4 million?
Did you get an outside
investment in '18?
We raised $2 million.
How much cash
do you have in the bank?
We have $1.5 million.
Did you generate
enough margins ‐‐
Did you raise more money?
Sorry, Mark.
Wait. We did.
We did raise more money.
Ah, there you go.
So, the existing investors
invested another 1.5.
At what valuation?
And what was
the valuation then?
$15 million.
Sharks: 15?!
Mullin: Yes.
What you're asking today.
Yes.
That's insane!
So personally, like,
I like very,
very weak coffee
and I love to get behind
what I do a deal with.
But the packaging,
I don't think,
conveys what
this is about.
It says "pour‐over set."
If I walked by this
in a store,
I would have thought
it was some type of glass.
That's why I think that
the digital is working for you
and the stores
not so much.
So, I love the idea,
I think you're smart as can be,
very cool,
but I'm out.
♪♪
You seem to grow
in plateaus.
You seem to get to
a point...
Right.
...something happens,
you raise money.
Right.
You're at that plateau.
How do you get to
that next step?
Right. What's your secret sauce?
What's your secret sauce?
What's happening now is that,
you know, we've grown a lot ‐‐
like this past month,
we made $350,000,
and again, really,
really close to breaking even.
How much you think
you'll lose this year?
We'll probably lose
around $700,000.
Lose $700,000?
O'Leary: $700,000.
But that's OK.
That's not the issue for you.
Why is it always OK,
Mark?
That's because if
you can grow your way
out of those losses ‐‐
if you can keep on growing...
Right. Right.
Then let me just work with
the numbers for a second.
Wait, wait. Wait, no.
Let her answer my question.
Can we hear the answer
to the question?
Which question? Is it OK
to lose money every year?
Which one do we have here?
What I ‐‐
What I'm really excited about
in the next phase
is that we made $250,000
online last month.
O'Leary: OK.
What did you make
in profit from that?
So we made about $120,000.
So the real question becomes,
your next six months,
what are you
going to do in revenue,
and what are you
going to do in profits?
In the next six months, we plan
to make another $3.5 million
In sales.
Then we were planning to
make $500,000 profit there.
There we go.
So that's ‐‐
That'll be the first time.
First time. Mm‐hmm.
So I have to pay
a $15 million valuation
to see if maybe,
for the first time ever,
this 4‐year‐old business can go
cash flow positive, right?
And that's really common,
though,
with a consumer
packaged‐goods business.
You've raised
a ton of money,
burned through
quite a bit of it.
How much do you still own
of the company?
I still own 40%.
So you've lost control of it
through these raises, right?
Uh, technically, yes.
You know, Debbie,
this is a very expensive bet
that I'm not
going to take.
I'm out.
Debbie, you want me to ‐‐
you want me to be ‐‐
you want me
to tell you the truth?
Yes.
This?
Amazing, right?
Thank you.
Lost $700,000 then lost
another couple of million,
have 1.4 million
in the bank.
You burn through all
that money, and you go,
"Well, that's very common
in a startup."
What would the everyday person
say about that right now?
They'd say,
"Go make some money."
Yeah.
They'd say,
"Go make some money."
The everyday person
would say,
"I just lost my job
and my house."
Mm‐hmm.
The everyday person
might say to you,
"You got $1.4 million
in the bank.
What are you doing
for others right now?"
Instead of asking
for more money, right?
That's a great question.
Yes, yeah.
Yeah, but Daymond,
that is so unfair.
But that ‐‐
That's not unfair.
That's just so unfair.
That is my belief.
I don't care.
That's not even a belief.
You want to lose $1.4 million,
give it to me.
I'm cool with that,
alright?
What about the flip side?
She's trying to create jobs.
She's trying to bust her ass,
make money, and create jobs.
What about the flip side?
She's burned through enough
to give to enough people
to create other jobs.
So that means no one
should ever start a business.
That's socialism,
Daymond.
Herjavec: Daymond. Daymond.
That is so unfair.
John:
I don't care if it's unfair.
That's my belief.
Socialism?
That's Marxism.
I don't care.
You know what?
When I started with my goods,
I didn't have $1 million.
I didn't have $10,000.
No, no, no. I'm not ‐‐
I'm not questioning your belief.
What I'm saying to you ‐‐
I don't care about
what they say. I'm out.
Alright. Debbie ‐‐
OK, well, Daymond, I would like
to just reiterate ‐‐
You can talk to them,
because they're so caring.
He's out.
Debbie, so...
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
There are some companies
that need to make money
along the way ‐‐
I'm with Daymond 100% ‐‐
but you know,
I'm in tech.
Most companies in tech
have to start
with a lot of investment,
and it takes a while
to break even, so I get that.
I mean, I think ‐‐ I think
you're the real deal.
Thank you.
So I'll make you
an offer.
I'll give you the $600,000
for 8%.
I know it's aggressive,
but it's what
I feel comfortable with.
Look, the challenge
of this horrific COVID period,
as an investor, is
as trends accelerate ‐‐
in this case,
going to online ‐‐
you don't know
what demand is organic,
what demand is temporary,
and so because
I just don't know
what the demand drivers
are,
for those reasons,
I'm out.
♪♪
What about 4% plus
1.5 advisory shares?
I don't care
how you get me to 8%.
Five point ‐‐
How about 5.5%?
To Mark's point, my gut tells me
you're onto something,
but there's so much
uncertainty right now,
so I'm pricing in
the element of risk.
That's why I want the 8%.
♪♪
I would love to take
your offer.
Done! All right!
Awesome.
High five!
Thank you. Yay!
[ Laughs ]
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you, guys, very much.
Thank you, Debbie.
Great job.
Mullin:
I took Robert's offer,
even though it cut my valuation
in half,
because I really think
that he's going to
bring so much to the business.
In these times,
even though we're on track
to being profitable,
we always want to kind of know
what's the next thing,
and I think that someone
like Robert
can really help us
think that through
and also really help us
with a lot of
the marketing opportunities
that a Shark can bring
to a brand like ours.
A lot of entrepreneurs think,
"I'm going to start a company,
and the first thing
I have to do is raise money."
That's wrong.
They failed to learn ‐‐
That's what happened here.
Well, no,
a lot of people think
just by raising money,
they've accomplished something.
It's not an accomplishment.
It's an obligation.
But that doesn't
always work, Mark.
Greiner: Exactly. Exactly.
Well, I can't sleep
if I lose a dollar
of somebody else's money.
I don't like the casual,
"It's OK
burning a couple of million
to launch a brand."
O'Leary: She is not ‐‐
That is so disrespectful
to the hustle she's put in.
That's 100% wrong.
Yeah, that's 100% wrong.
You know how many people
are hustling? Everybody hustles.
Oh, my God. She put
four years' hustle into this?
Sometimes you got to spend money
to make money.
I know it's a cliché.
Well, you know what?
But it buys you time.
You put your money
where your mouth was,
and I agree with that ‐‐
I respect what you did.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank
is an easier way
to hold your favorite beverage.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks, my name
is Destiny Padgett,
and I'm from the small town
of Buna, Texas.
I'm seeking $200,000
for 10% equity in my company.
Sharks, around the world,
we all share a common need ‐‐
We all need a drink, am I right?
And no one likes holding a drink
that's ice‐cold wet
and dripping in condensation.
Whether you're drinking
a protein shake
from an ice‐shaker bottle,
an iced coffee
from a local cafe,
or just a brewski
while kicking it with the boys,
nobody wants
sweaty, clammy hands.
And, just like us,
our drinks come in
all different shapes and sizes.
So tell me,
why don't we have more sleeves
to fit all the beverages?
Well, Sharks, now we do.
Introducing LIT Handlers,
a revolutionary way
to consume your beverage
with style and efficiency.
These bad boys aren't just
your regular old run‐of‐the‐mill
insulators.
Our patent pending handlers have
an easy‐to‐grip handle
that's built
right into the sleeve
to help redistribute the weight.
That's not all, though.
We've also added a pocket
inside the reinforced handle,
so no more worrying about
leaving your go‐tos behind.
Easily slide
your lip balm, your pen,
or even your car key
in our cute and stylish pocket.
So tell me, Sharks.
Are you ready to get
a handle on it?
Cuban: Absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
‐Good job.
‐Great job.
Thank you!
[ Giggles ]
So, Destiny,
before we get going,
tell us about yourself.
OK. I'm 31.
I'm from Buna.
Where is Buna?
[ Laughs ] It's in
the middle of nowhere.
I'm about 30 minutes
from Louisiana.
So when I was 17,
I moved to Utah.
I finished high school there,
I went to a little bit
of hair school,
I met a guy, I got pregnant,
and so then I moved to Texas.
I moved back in with my parents,
and from there,
I mean, I was pregnant,
so I had to do something
to take care of my kid.
And in 2014,
I started my first Etsy store.
And I've just been growing
and glowing since, y'all.
I have to say,
this is extremely comfortable.
Yes.
Sometimes the simplest
things are the best solutions.
But if I had to just hold it
myself like this,
it's a pain.
Yeah.
This is really good.
Why can't somebody
just knock you off?
Well, I do have
the pending patents.
Herjavec:
What's your patent on?
It on the pocket
with the handle.
Which is ingenious,
right?
Where is the pocket?
It just makes it
so much easier.
Oh, it's in
the handle. OK.
There's no pocket.
I could put my pen
in here...
There is.
Your spoon was in it.
Oh.
So I could be ready to sign
a contract at any moment.
That's right.
On the ready.
[ Laughs ]
OK, what's
your best seller?
It's really a tie between
this slim that's in your hand,
the pint‐size ice cream,
and the 30‐ounce size.
Herjavec:
Do you make these by hand?
No, sir. No.
They're manufactured
overseas in China.
So what are your sales,
Destiny?
Wow.
Year to date,
we are at 630.
‐Whoa!
‐Wow!
‐Nice!
$630,000?
What?!
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Thousand?
Yes, sir.
Daaaang!
‐Wow.
‐Whoa!
Wow, this story got really
interesting real fast.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I have to admit,
I thought it was
a total piece of [bleep]
but it's actually
pretty good.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
It's an easier way
to eat ice cream,
that's for sure. Right?
It is.
Does somebody else
make one
with a handle
and no pocket?
So, right after I did
my first run of these,
before I had the pocket,
someone in China, they started
trying to sell them.
Oh, you were getting
knocked off.
Yes.
On the 30‐ounce size.
With the pocket
or without the pocket?
Without the pocket.
You own 100%
of the company?
100%.
Do you have
any loans?
Nope.
And what do you think you're
on track to do this year?
It's amazing.
Thank you.
I'm on track to do $780,000.
Wow.
So how much does
this cost you to make?
Let's just say
this size.
That size costs me $1.20,
landed.
For wholesale,
we sell them for $3.19
in minimums of three,
and retail on that is $8.99.
Our biggest size,
the 30‐ounce size,
it costs me $1.60.
Wholesale is $4.44,
minimum of three.
Retail on that
is $12.99.
Destiny,
I gotta tell you ‐‐
you are a wolf
in sheep's clothing.
[ Laughs ] Thank you.
You know,
you came out here
and you're bubbly
and you're fun,
and then, bam!
Cuban: Boom!
You know your numbers.
What percentage of your sales
are wholesale,
and what percentage
are retail?
It is split
right down the middle.
Is it from Etsy, mostly,
or do you also sell
from your own website?
I sell from my website,
I sell from Etsy,
and I sell on Amazon.
And what will you net
this year?
I'm hoping I net
around $200,000.
Yeah!
Wow! Nice.
So what do you need
the money for?
Um, I really want y'all.
I ‐‐ With the money, though,
I would just keep growing.
I really want help
with licensing ‐‐
I want to be able
to do sports ones,
I want to be in bookstores,
college bookstores.
I didn't go to college for this.
So, my dad was an entrepreneur.
My mom was a photographer.
All six of their kids
are entrepreneurs.
I have a little pool of people
that I can call
and ask things to,
but they've never done anything
on this kind of scale.
How's that feel to be in
a family of entrepreneurs?
Two parents and
one of six kids,
and you're the kick‐ass
entrepreneur.
My sister hates it.
[ Laughs ]
O'Leary: Listen, Destiny,
it's a simple business,
but it's working.
I like it. I don't have
LIT Handlers in my portfolio.
[ Laughs ]
So I'll make you an offer.
I'll do it for 20%.
I'll give you 200 grand.
OK. 200 for 20.
That's somewhat ‐‐
Herjavec: Wow.
O'Leary: Yeah.
Wasn't expecting that,
Kevin.
Listen, I want to get
in the family.
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
We would welcome you in
with open arms.
Destiny, you've done
an amazing job
of growing this business.
I mean, truly, I really don't
think you need an investor.
I think you've done
an incredible job,
and I think
you'll figure it out.
So I appreciate
the opportunity, but I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
I'm sorry.
I'm the tall one.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
Destiny, congratulations.
I mean, lots of people
can get sales.
Not a lot of people can get
$200,000 in profits
and just be
getting started.
Mm‐hmm.
So, I mean, what you've
accomplished is incredible,
but I don't think
it'd be a great fit for me.
But for those reasons,
I'm out.
Alright. Thank you, Mark.
You're welcome.
I got the name right
this time, y'all.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I really don't think
that you need a partner.
You're already there.
You're on all the platforms.
You're getting
your own manufacturing.
You really picked good ‐‐
good designs.
Thank you.
I wish you good luck.
I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Daymond,
what are you going to do?
♪♪
I guess ‐‐ Hey, listen.
If I have to roll up my sleeves
with my team on this,
then we're just going to
need a little bit more.
I'll offer you $200,000
for 25%.
OK. So we have 25% and 20%.
I'm going to raise mine
to 25%.
I'm better than he is.
Greiner: Mm!
Oh, my g‐‐
O'Leary: So now
you got to choose.
Because I've been
in this space now,
we know who the premium
companies are to sell goods to
that are going to
put logos on,
and we're already
talking to them.
Mm‐hmm.
And that's why I feel
the value is there,
because we could probably
increase the company
by a large amount
and then get you
what you want ‐‐
licensing and all
that kind of stuff.
So that's where I feel
the value is.
Yeah. Would you be willing
to go to 20%?
If you do it right now
and don't look at Kevin.
Done.
Alright!
There we go.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Congrats.
Well, I'm glad
I saved you 5%.
Cuban: Congratulations,
Destiny.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, Destiny.
Thanks, y'all.
‐She's great.
‐How fun was she?
I think she's terrific.
♪♪
Padgett: I just made a deal
with Daymond.
This means everything.
This means we're going to grow
and be a multimillion‐dollar
company. [ Laughs ]
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a product
to aid an important
childhood milestone.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Hola, Sharks.
My name is Judy Abrahams.
I am from San Andrés Island,
Colombia,
and I am the Queen
of Potty Training.
And I am Chris Guerrera,
and I am the King of
Manufacturing.
We are seeking $300,000
for 10% of our company...
Dang.
...the Super Potty Trainer.
Herjavec: Wow.
Sharks, potty training
can be stressful,
scary, and
a messy experience
for both the parent
and the child.
So, let's say adiós
to those bulky tops,
bye to those soiled seats,
and say hello
to the Super Potty Trainer,
the perfect training device
to quickly and safely
potty train your child
to go like a pro.
Like a pro.
[ Laughter ]
So Sharks, let me
show you how it works.
Simply take
your Super Potty Trainer,
lift up your toilet seat,
place the Super Potty Trainer
in position,
lower your seat,
and that's it.
The Super Potty Trainer
has a steady back support
that allows the child
to sit directly on the toilet
on day one.
Also, the Super Potty Trainer
has some nonskid pads
that makes it adjustable.
Wow.
The Super Potty Trainer
is the real deal here ‐‐
is the real tool to potty train
your child in no time.
So Sharks, let's fill your banks
with a lot of cash.
‐Yowza.
‐Whoo!
Cuban: Yowza.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Let's get down
to business...
Together: With
the Super Potty Trainer!
‐Ha!
‐[ Chuckles ]
Uh, great idea.
Great idea.
Yay!
I have a question,
Judy, though.
Won't the baby's back
just push it back?
Because I have
2 1/2‐year‐old twins,
so I'd have it
right at the front.
Wouldn't they push it back
right away when they sat on it?
No, because you have
the nonskid pads.
Yeah?
So if the child is small,
you move it forward
and it doesn't move.
It doesn't move.
It does not move.
So with the weight of the child
and the nonskid pads,
that's your break.
And it grows with the child.
You don't need anything else.
That is a cool idea.
It's a really good
idea, yeah.
So, tell us about you.
How did you come up with this?
So back in 2012,
I was trying to
potty train my daughter.
She was struggling,
so I quit my job
to potty train her.
‐You quit your job?
I quit my job.
To potty train
your child?
Yeah, because when the child
is afraid
of going down on the potty,
they won't go.
My daughter is deathly afraid.
It can be really stressful.
Yeah. So when they are
really afraid, they hold it.
Yes.
And then ‐‐ So that's
what happened to my daughter.
So the magic moment was when
she, with her own words ‐‐
she was almost 3 ‐‐
she said, like,
"If you sit on the toilet,
I'll sit with you."
So this is what I did.
I sat down on
the toilet with her,
she sat in front of me,
so my stomach
became her back support
and she went number two
several times that day.
So that worked because
you were there with her?
Yes, I thought, at some point,
I cannot be on the toilet
the whole day with her.
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm a legal assistant.
I used all that background
that I have,
and I said,
"I have an invention."
So that day, I did
all the legal research
and I filed for a patent.
I have my utility patent.
And Chris, what do you do?
What's your background?
Herjavec:
And who are you?
OK, so I'm a guy
that comes out of
corporate America.
I'm on patents
for Ford Motor Company
and ran BMW plants.
So, I come into play here
with the manufacturing side,
where we can do all of this
in the USA,
and we can do it for $2.30
for my cost.
Wow.
And with higher volume,
I can do it below $2.
Let's talk about sales.
OK, so we launched this
in March.
Wow.
Lots of good sales volume
with a big, big box.
Who?
Walmart.
OK, sales, sales.
So, in six months,
we're at $65,000 in sales.
How many stores are you in?
Just under 400.
Chris, that's not exciting.
What's your packaging
look like? Do we see it?
That's it.
Just this?
With the sticker?
No, it's in a display box.
Stay on the numbers.
$65,000.
Right.
Breaking news ‐‐
you're not worth $3 million.
Well, hang on, Kevin.
There's more to the story.
Abrahams: Kevin, wait.
I need to finish
telling you the numbers.
John: They're not done yet.
OK.
So, now, Walmart's going to
carry us through next spring.
Yes.
And they made a commitment
to put us in 4,800 stores
which is a $1.1 million P. O.
Yes.
And Menards
just made a commitment
to put us in 350 stores.
Yes.
So you have a $1.1 million
purchase order?
I ‐‐ I have
in talks of it.
I don't physically
have ‐‐
Sharks: Ohhh!
We don't have it yet.
‐No.
‐But they ‐‐ they ‐‐
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
However, they are concerned
about the lack of actual sales
of Judy and Chris' business,
Super Potty Trainer.
So, you have a $1.1 million
purchase order?
I ‐‐ I have
in talks of it.
I don't physically
have ‐‐
Sharks: Ohhh!
I don't have it yet.
‐No.
‐But they ‐‐ they ‐‐
Abrahams: Listen.
O'Leary: Breaking news,
breaking news,
back to not where you were
with $3 million.
I think I'm just trying
to understand, because ‐‐
because if you have
a purchase order,
you have a purchase order.
I think ‐‐
So, when Walmart said to you,
"I'm giving you a commitment,"
what does that mean?
So Walmart said,
with the pandemic, right,
everybody's sales were flat
completely for two months.
There was nobody
in the stores.
Not digital direct.
You know,
I got to tell you,
kids are still pooing
during the pandemic.
Yep.
So Walmart says,
"Let's carry you
through the holiday,
and if the sales continue
to grow the way they're growing,
we're going to put you
in all the stores for 2021."
Are you still talking about it,
or is it real?
No, it's real.
Greiner: Wait.
But the P. O. isn't.
You know how many guys
have come in here, Chris...
Understand.
...telling us they got their
million‐dollar Walmart P. O.?
Then we start probing...
Yeah.
...and it's we're talking,
we're liking, they're liking.
John: Chris, what was your
sell‐through
through the doors of Walmart?
What was the sell‐through?
Greiner: Right.
Guerrera:
So, 356 stores.
It's about 600 a month.
600 units a month?
Correct.
Is this two units
in a month?
I think you're right.
It's about two.
That's a low number.
I mean, is it the advertising?
Is it confusing?
Because I'm looking at
this toddler ‐‐
I never seen a toddler taking
a dump reading a good book.
I've never seen that.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe people are thinking
you're just trying to
sell a book or something.
Look, it's cute.
I get it.
I think ‐‐
It's adorable.
I've just never seen it.
I'm confused.
I can tell you
the customer feedback
has been pretty strong.
Yes.
Cuban: So, OK,
the product looks great.
I remember with my son,
trying to get him potty trained,
it was hard.
It was a pain in the butt.
Yes.
But you priced it
as if you already have
three years of great results.
Yes.
And you don't.
And that's the challenge,
and so for those reasons,
I'm out, guys.
I'm sorry, Mark.
Herjavec: Chris, you got to
walk me through that.
Like, I love the product,
but you're pricing this thing
on potential commitments
from Walmart.
You're telling me
this is worth $3 million
and you've got $60,000 in sales.
Your valuation is so nuts,
we're never going to get there.
I'm out.
You came here too early,
and you asked too much.
I'm sorry, my friends.
King and Queen of
Super Potty Trainer, I'm out.
♪♪
Thank you, Kevin.
Thank you.
John: Yeah, but, I mean,
you've seen the show ‐‐
I mean, we've been on
over a decade.
You knew we were going to
give you a problem about that.
I mean, you didn't do
your homework on that?
We did.
But then why would you value
the company so much
with literally no sales?
They t‐‐
You're very optimistic,
which you should be ‐‐
I mean, it is a great product.
But you're charging us again
on the future.
So make me an offer,
Daymond, really.
You know what? I would insult
you to make you an offer
because first of all ‐‐
Equity of the company,
don't let it go away from you.
I'd insult you, because ‐‐
How many ‐‐ How many units
do you have in inventory?
Uh, 3,500 right now.
‐3,500.
‐Wow.
So, that's, right there,
the underlying problem, right?
You know, during four months
or five months
after COVID hit,
you were unable to market those
and sell those units
direct to the customer.
I think that's what
we're all saying up here.
And then it's just
a high valuation.
I mean, listen,
if Lori was interested,
then maybe I'd come in
with her,
because she's the Queen of Poo,
you know.
When it comes to number two,
she's number one.
Abrahams: Lori, that's why.
You know what I mean? But ‐‐
Do you really mean that?
Herjavec: Ha‐ha.
He's been saying that
for 10 years.
Abrahams: Listen.
Lori, we have to ‐‐
Daymond, if you want to
go in with me...
Please.
...we can go 50/50.
And my feeling is
that we would have to give you
the $300,000.
Hold on, Lori.
Yep.
Are you writing me
a note?
No, go ahead. Say it.
50%.
O'Leary:
So, 300,000 for 50%.
Exactly where I was at. See?
Oh, that's so funny.
Listen, that's better
than nothing.
You got an offer ‐‐ 50%.
That's a great offer.
I'm shocked.
So we'll give you the $300,000
for 50%,
and then we will figure out
who we license it to
and see if we can get somebody
to take this under their wing
and spread you out nationwide
in all retailers.
For me, that is
what this needs right now,
and it will sell,
and you will not regret it.
Lori, from Queen to Queen...
[ Laughs ]
...you got a sweet deal,
so we'll take your offer.
Oh, good! Yay.
[ Cheering ]
Thank you, Daymond, and
thank you, guys. Thank you.
And now you have made Daymond
also the King of Poo.
Cuban: Well done.
Congratulations.
All right, listen, you're
no fool when it comes to stool.
‐Hey, congrats, guys.
‐Thank you, guys.
Congratulations.
‐You're welcome.
‐Thank you.
Did not see that one coming.
Me either.
[ Crying ]
Oh, my God.
Abrahams: Lori and Daymond
have no idea
what they just did
to my life.
I have struggled financially
for a long time,
and I have worked so hard
for the Super Potty Trainer
because I know
it's an amazing product.
Can I get a hug?
Abrahams: "Shark Tank"
changed my life.
I'm living the American dream.
I can't believe it.
This is amazing.
We got two Sharks, not one.
We got two Sharks!
I know. [ Laughs ]
Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪